and part of what I think is so
interesting about your work is you
literally named the blog rogue health
and fitness right you're going rogue
from kind of the standard ideas around
what to eat how to exercise and things
like that and so I thought maybe what we
could do is let's start on the diet side
right most people are taught kind of a
low fat high carb type diet and they
basically eat you know what they
consider to be that food pyramid you
obviously have a different view of the
world so maybe kind of talk about the
work you've done and why you've arrived
at something that's different but are
kind of rogue to those traditional
recommendations okay great so I think
that a lot of this a lot of the way
people eat and you know how they're
recommended to eat and so on it flows
from one one single light idea and that
idea is a wrong idea and and it's
basically the idea that saturated fat
causes heart disease this this goes back
to you know the 40s and 50s and and the
nutritionist and selkies and the
cholesterol idea and so on and and they
hit on the idea that saturated fat was
killing people it was it was a huge
problem at the time art disease it's
still a big problem but he hits mostly
much older people now at the time they
were looking at a lot of middle-aged men
dropping dead heart attacks and so on so
they hit on this idea and in retrospect
it you know looking at looking at what
we know now and the research it seems
wholly mistaken nevertheless by the late
1970s the US government had latched on
to it and put out official dietary
recommendations that we should avoid
eating a lot of saturated fat that we
should eat a lot of whole grain
that fruits and vegetables were uniquely
healthy and so on and so forth and that
is basis for how how most people are
eating now I let me back up a little
front as far as saturated fat goes there
have been several meta analyses which
are basically reviews of studies done in
the last decade that have shown that
intake of dietary saturated fat is not
related to coronary heart disease so I
come from a perspective of thinking why
do why does the Western world the modern
Western world suffer from these diseases
like heart disease and cancer and
Alzheimer's diabetes and so on and and
why I have these all increased in recent
years and why do some other societies
not have them essentially you know for
example there is there's a there's an
island in the South Pacific the taverns
the island of Catawba where these people
live and they have no chronic disease
whatsoever as far as they found you know
people have gone there and investigate
them and that despite the fact that
seventy-five percent of the men smoked
cigarettes so you know I mean I'm not
you know not saying that cigarettes are
behind by any means but I'm just saying
I'm pointing out this fact why do these
people have seemingly no chronic disease
if you go back in time why did these
even even in the Western world
why were these diseases so scarce and
why are they common now well my my main
conclusion is that chronic diseases are
as someone has said they
might be better terms and diseases of
processed food so in the late 19th
century there were technologies
developed for example that were able to
make white flour there was there was
little to no white flour before that but
then they you know with with the
Industrial Revolution and these gigantic
milling machines they were L make white
flour and everybody started using it
sugar has been around a little bit
longer but it became a lot cheaper and
so as it became cheaper and cheaper
people started using more of it a couple
hundred years ago and in the US you know
per capita consumption was like five
pounds a year or something like that
whereas it's you know in the range of
one hundred and fifty pounds now and
then one other one other invention that
happened in the late 19th century was
they figured out how to extract oils
from seeds so they this started out
actually as a way to try to make cotton
seeds which were a waste product
profitable to get something out of them
and they did and ultimately they made
Crisco the the laughs the CEO on that
last part of Crisco stands for
cottonseed oil and they applied this to
a number you know a different oil so now
for example soybean oil is is the most
common oil and you know corn oil canola
oil you know etc all these oils so you
put those all together and you've got
modern food and you put them you put
them together in a certain way in
certain combinations and you've got
modern ultra processed food that people
eat huge amounts of so in the United
States approximately 60% of calories in
the average diet comes from these ultra
processed foods so that
a huge amount so these are these are
what I'm talking about specifically are
the kind of foods that come in boxes and
bags that are brightly labeled have
brand names that are found in the middle
aisles of the supermarket and and that's
what most people eat so that is what has
caused our modern epidemic of crime
disease in my estimation now we've had
even you know a lot of this goes back to
the invention of Agriculture right so it
is so before agriculture everyone was a
hunter-gatherer everyone ate meat and
whatever whatever wild vegetation they
could gather and as far as we know they
suffered from none of these described
diseases that we have now
then when agricultural agriculture was
invented people started eating lots of
grains and they started suffering from a
lot of chronic diseases for example a
really good example of this is that
before agriculture the average man was
something like five foot nine inches
tall after agriculture they were five
foot three and there was all kinds of
you know within with his same you know
proportionate decrease in women and you
know they found in skeletons the
skeletal remains that have been studied
and so on crime disease as
osteoarthritis so on and so forth
infectious diseases also also became
very prominent at any rate we lived like
that for a long time in in recent years
who say the nineteenth century people
started getting much taller again due to
better nutrition
but then we took a second hit we took
this industrial food hit that I was just
talking about starting around 1900 safe
heart disease started right at rising as
it as an epidemic basically in in 1900
there was essentially zero heart disease
famous cardiologist Paul Dudley white
who was the most famous cardiologist at
mid-century said that when he was
training in the early years of the
century nobody ever talked about
coronary artery disease because nobody
had know they didn't know it existed and
then people started having heart attacks
and so on till by midnight mid 20th
century you you had huge you know huge
numbers of heart attacks and so on heart
disease epidemic so then you know fast
forward to a couple of decades ago and
then we had these Dietary Guidelines
after they decided that saturated fat
was bad and then the obesity epidemic
started going right about that time is
that a coincidence
I don't think so there are other factors
I believe but the fact that people were
told to eat less meat and animal
products and eat more carbohydrates I
believe very much contributed to it so
there we are there there's there's the
food element and that's that that is my
explanation of why this has happened